hello and welcome to grenade October is
upon us and the huge video game releases
continue to drop the real heavy hitters
that want your valuable play time are
here but there's also a few hidden gems
we'll showcase - let's do this
here's nine games releasing in October
2018 we'll start with the Beast the
behemoth the game that wants you for
five years Red Dead Redemption - out on
the ps4 and Xbox one on October 26th
eight years after we played the first of
rockstars Red Dead games we're going
back but this time it's a prequel
telling the story of the van der Linde
gang John was sent to kill we play as
Arthur Morgan as the gang of Outlaws are
pursued and hunted by federal agents
imagine GTA 5 in the Wild West and
you're on the right tracks instead of
cars for travel we'll have horses but
they do include stats like stamina speed
and loyalty the game is so vast there
are more than 200 types of animals to
hunt in the game and that's just a
single side quest prepared to rob banks
hijack trains and live in the last vigil
of the Wild West we've had a Call of
Duty title every year for 13 years now
so it comes as no surprise that another
one releases this month call of duty
black ops 4 on PC ps4 and Xbox one on
October the 12th you know what to expect
an expertly polished first-person
shooter able to hit 60 frames per second
on console which is no easy feat but
there are serious differences to note
with black ops 4 firstly there is no
single-player mode no story mode no
campaign to experience - some that's a
bitter pill to swallow as the antics of
soap and price in modern warfare all the
way black ops follows on from world at
war there were so important pieces of
law to many people well now we live in
the time of battle royal and the
development time needed for the campaign
has been injected into black out Call of
Duty's version of battle royale 100
soldiers wingsuit down onto the
battlefield and only one survives I have
to admit it's a really good game mode I
played it and I loved it but it made me
rage quit anyone interested in seeing me
become toxic hmm
what Knight and Pogue G need to be we're
here a real contender is arriving on
October 12th worldwide
Assassin's Creed became an annual video
game franchise and overtime that took
its toll on the series Ubisoft decided
to take a year off the triple-a version
of the game and returned last year with
the excellent Assassin's Creed origins
achieving some of the highest review
scores to date well they decided to go
back to an annual release and this month
Assassin's Creed Odyssey hit shelves on
October 2nd the mechanics and RPG
staples remain the same as lashya with
small updates everywhere the most
notable are the visual overhauls as we
play as Alexios or Cassandra mercenaries
who are directly descendants of King
Leonidas making the game around four
hundred years earlier than origins as
always the dedication to history and
storytelling will be present will making
a game every single year be possible or
will the game suffer as history has
shown in the past are you grabbing it
I'd love to know your thoughts let's
look at spot WWE 2k 19 ok spots
Entertainment them it's still real to me
damn it on October the 9th double w ee
2k 19 hits the ps4 Xbox and PC with many
annual games it can be difficult to
surmise what changes from last year so
he goes the roster boasts over 200
superstars and is confirmed to be the
largest in their history the showcase
mode returns again and this year you'll
be reliving Daniel Bryan's career up to
the moment he finally achieved his dream
my career mode has once again improved
with voice acting from an impressive
amount of the locker room all in all if
you like a bit of ruslan this series
continues to improve every year oh and
if you get the deluxe version you can
play four days earlier on October the
fifth ever heard of the Cthulhu it was a
short story written back in 1926 almost
100 years later it's getting its own
video game on October 30th we'll be
filling the shoes of Edward Pierce a
private detective looking to solve the
death of an entire family if you haven't
guessed already this is a psychological
horror outing the Cthulhu is said to be
like an octopus dragon being designed to
scare the SH out of you if you want to
wet yourself with fear be ready on
October 30th for the Call of Cthulhu the
action role-playing games known as the
soul series are being re-released
together on October 19th the Dark Souls
trilogy on Xbox
- and ps4 it includes all the DLC but
here's something strange they aren't
releasing it in Europe weird isn't it
running at 60 frames per second with
dedicated servers and even the password
matchmaking from Dark Souls 3 has been
added to the game if you were one of the
few people who missed Dark Souls the
first time around grab this and prepare
to die so bloody many times any
beat-em-up fans in the house Soul
Calibur 6 is available on October the
19th on ps4 PC and Xbox although it
never really gets the attention it
deserves due to Tekken and Street
Fighter Soul Calibur continues to garner
good reviews and has ultra impressive
cameos such as Geralt from The Witcher
here's something different the
occupation this game lasts four hours
exactly four hours you may think that's
not long enough well hear me out because
this could be brilliant over those four
real-time hours you can interact with
many characters shaping your experience
they call it dynamic artificial
intelligence in other words you and I
can play a game at the same time and
we'd experience completely different
contrasting sites and interactions this
isn't a happy-go-lucky story as the plot
starts with a terror attack killing 23
people everything is set back in 1987 in
the UK so expect terrible accents um
kind of like mine oh no Tarquin the
occupation drops on October the 9th and
finally as they're becoming such a huge
part of gaming I'm including a DLC this
month for spider-man on ps4 on October
the 23rd we can jump back in to Spidey's
New York and team up with black cat who
got away from us in the base game she's
planning the ultimate heist and we've
been promised another super villain is
waiting to do battle with Peter in terms
of content no new mechanics are intended
to be added this is simply Marv
spider-man on ps4 which suits me
completely so there we have it 9 video
games to help you get through the month
of October what are you buy-in it's a
tough choice isn't it this month my bank
balance won't be happy oh and if you're
wondering where the heck battlefield 5
is well that's been delayed until
November so we'll cover that next month
I'm Adam from PlayStation granade it's
been a pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]